mit schwerem gerät durch fühlen beamte
einer einsatzhundertschaft einen acker
in der nähe von bremen gesucht wird die
leiche von marco w der 46-jährige ist
seit einem jahr verschwunden und die
staatsanwaltschaft glaubt an bord und
hat jetzt endlich den beweis dafür
marco b aus bremen er ist seit einem
jahr vermisst die beamten die gehen fest
davon aus dass der 46-jährige tot ist
deshalb hat eine hundertschaft jetzt ein
ganzes feld in posthausen bei bremen
umgegraben um seine leiche dort zu
finden ja und dafür wurde ein extrem
hoher aufwand betrieben schweres gerät
rückte an und der acker wurde quasi auf
links gedreht aber warum ist sich die
staatsanwaltschaft überhaupt so sicher
dass es mord war und wurde unter der
erde auch was gefunden astrid sievert
und corinna perotti wissen er
warum musste marco w sterben jetzt ist
klar drei männer haben ihn umgebracht
zerstückelt und die leichenteile rund um
bremen vergraben darum wurde auch auf
diesem feld bei posthausen zwei tage
geburt gegraben das halbe feld mit einer
hundertschaft an polizisten mit schwerem
gerät umgepflügt der vermissten der
lippe immer ungewöhnlicher wir befinden
uns 40 autominuten entfernt von der
bremer neustadt von dem wohnsitz von
marco w auf einem ehemaligen leifeld und
vor wenigen tagen wurde das feld hier
regelrecht durchpflügt durchkämmt meter
tief in die erde gegangen mit erdbeeren
baggern
leichenspürhunden es war ein riesen
polizeieinsatz auf der suche nach der
leiche von marco w
jetzt der durchbruch auf einem ähnlichen
feld haben polizisten offenbar
leichenteile des vermissten gefunden
bisher hat die leiche gefehlt die haben
wir uns gesucht ist zwischenzeitlich bei
den durchgeführten grabungs maßnahmen
leichenteile gefunden worden die aktuell
rechtsmedizinisch untersucht werden ob
es sich hierbei um die sterblichen
überreste der gesuchten personen handelt
das können wir aktuell noch nicht
abschließend sagen denn hierzu muss im
weiteren die dna-untersuchung oder das
ergebnis der durchzuführenden dna
untersuchungen abgewartet werden die
drei tatverdächtigen sitzen unterdessen
in diesem bremer gefängnis in
untersuchungshaft
mitte oktober hat sich der jüngste von
denen 3 1 wohl selbst bei der polizei
gemeldet vielleicht das schlechte
gewissen man kann es nur mutmaßen und
hat berichtet und vor wenigen tagen
wurden auch die zwei ältere männer
festgenommen
wir müssen aktuell davon ausgehen dass
die leichen zerstückelt worden ist
jedenfalls haben die drei beschuldigten
übereinstimmt dies so angegeben die
bremer neustadt hier lebte marco w bis
zu seinem mysteriösen verschwinden vor
18 monaten
doch erst im oktober 2020 wurde er als
vermisst gemeldet wie konnten die
mutmaßlichen täter das vertuschen
das handy angeeignet haben von ihrem
opfer die liste durchgegangen sind also
die kontaktliste und dann einfach mal
ein paar leute angeschrieben haben und
so getan haben als wenn
die polizei sucht nun weitere
leichenteile von marco w zur tat soll es
im april 2020 gekommen sein weil sich
zwei der drei tatverdächtigen mit dem
späteren opfer gestritten haben da sie
im miete für ihre wohnung schuldeten
marco w ermordet und zerstückelt wegen
1000 euro
ja wirklich ein ganz ganz schrecklicher
fall und sie sie können zur aufklärung
dieses falles beitragen wenn sie was
wissen dann melden sie sich doch bitte
bei der polizei in bremen unter
folgender rufnummer
0421 362 3 und dreimal die